[Music]
welcome to the f word Tonight is the
last of our heat and this time we're
opening our doors to the rest of the
world
as the year comes to an end so does my
search for the F word's best local
restaurant
this week I've been picking two of your
favorite restaurants to compete in the f
word kitchen make sure everything she
said now is absolutely perfect because
that'll make the difference between
winning and losing
I've held now biting heat for eight
International Cuisines and I've found
five of my semi-finalists already
Argentinian Steakhouse Santa Maria Del
Sur Indian restaurant La San Chinese
Sweet Mandarin simply tied from
Teddington and British restaurant the
pheasant
they're all through but who will I
choose to join them in the semi-finals
so far we've concentrated on your most
popular international cuisines
but Britain also boasts restaurants
serving delicious food from many other
countries so tonight we feature the very
best of these in my rest of the world
category
as Moroccan restaurant Ducan take on
Greek restaurant Red Cena so on all
these deserves to be absolutely perfect
yes both of them are hoping to secure a
place in next week's semi-finals
plus I make my own version of a classic
Greek ingredient halloumi cheese that's
not very big cheat is it
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening
how are you I'm nervous that's the
really nervous and excited to be here
absolutely what's the secret success
behind do cam what is it simple dishes
from uh my mum's cooking what's the
secret behind your cooking what is it
bear good quality cooking yes and keep
your customers happy that's what
tonight's all about if you want to make
it back to the semi-finals okay you need
to do Bloody well tonight okay because
only the top six high scores go through
to the semi-finals this needs to be the
best service of your lives
tonight Greek restaurant Red Cena and
Moroccan restaurant Ducan will battle
for a place in next week's semi-final
here's why I chose them
the ninth and final category my search
for f word's best local restaurants is
the rest of the world
from Japanese to Lebanese from polish to
Portuguese here in Britain we've got it
all
my team and I have been all over Britain
checking out your favorite restaurants
if I had this for lunch every day my
backside would be the size of a bus
after months of searching through an
extraordinary array of international
Cuisines we Whittle Daniel nominations
to two truly outstanding restaurants
both serve food from the Mediterranean
and I couldn't wait to put them to the
test
the first is Dukan in Wandsworth South
London
and serve classic Moroccan food and The
Man Behind it is Hospitality manager
turned owner Abdel
it's been asked time or time again where
the recommend a good Moroccan restaurant
in in London I genuinely couldn't and I
opened my own Duke and opened a year ago
and it's a hit with the locals
everything I've ever chosen at the menu
has been just delicious
Casablanca 20 years ago to study hotel
management in London but as he's
yearning to cook grew he started to
teach himself in his spare time
I am not a trained Chef I am self-taught
when I make dishes I don't look at a
book I just think of the core
ingredients and I keep on tweaking them
until it reaches all those senses that
are important for you to taste service
had nothing but price for khalil's food
so I decided to pay Duke and a visit
hello sir come this way please don't
excellent good to see you tell me the
success behind the restaurants it's just
passion for Moroccan Cuisine I just
cooked because my mother cooks
beautifully right I grew up in a
household with having lunch was like the
most important thing that happens I'm
glad that you're so passionate the fact
that it has to be authentic passionate
guy very passionate
from the outside looks like a little
cafe bar walk inside and there's a
little mini Oasis nice
kick off my Moroccan Feast Khalil brings
me a lamb's liver terrine it's the way
my mom used to make Lamb's liver I love
it and so the liver's been sauteed
that's right they've been actually
cooked twice very gently thank you very
much indeed
yeah the chocolate is delicious I mean
authentic started with cumin and he
cooked them twice very very quickly chop
them and then quickly again so for a guy
that's self-trained uh he definitely
knows how to cook next up is chicken
breast stuff with figs and almonds with
spice couscous
in terms of couscous do you steam that
or is it yeah it's steamed a lot of
people ask me you know how did you get
your couscous right and this really is
the simplest thing you can do just you
don't leave it alone no you need to give
it a little bit of love and attention
oh my God that's something
pretty good chicken stuffed with figs
with an apricot sauce sounds very very
sweet but he's managed to get the
balance absolutely spot on if we were in
the competition it'll mean so much to me
it's like the underdog winning the race
great lunch yeah you really enjoyed it
um it's been a tough decision I could
only put two rations through to cooking
the f word kitchen
and Ducan is one of them congratulations
absolutely brilliant really good thank
you and I'm very very happy absolutely
delicious you kept that authenticity and
that's really important for a local
eatery thank you very much you actually
filled my heart to enjoy we went
for shutters not even freshly trained
he's certainly been listening to his
mother that's for sure
and I think my mother would be proud
the other ration I've chosen from your
nominations in the rest of the world
category is in Bell size Park North
London
retina is a traditional family-run Greek
restaurant since his father retired 13
years ago son Minos has been managing
the business as soon as our family
business it's been going on for around
25 years so it's our life in one way or
another
minos's mother Zita has been cooking for
over 50 years but still refuses to hang
up her apron I like to be in the kitchen
I joined to be in the kitchen and
we really please
what makes Mama a great chef she's a
perfectionist you know she was brought
up with Greek food and she knows what
Greek food is all about
Vita's delicious Greek recipes keep red
Xena's customers coming back for more
the food is absolutely fantastic you
know you could just feel like the
quality of it is brilliant I've been to
quite a few Greek restaurants before but
this one's definitely the best
restaurant without a doubt
f word viewers gave her it seen as such
glowing testimonials I decided to go
there for lunch myself hello
hi there how are you nice to meet you
good to see you smells amazing and
where's the chef how are you I'm very
well thank you well nice to see you
thank you now what's for lunch today
what have you got as a special recipe
going in the oven we have the souvla
okay kebabs right roast potatoes okay
brilliant well I'll leave it to you
Rosita's lovely warm welcome I already
felt at home but would the food live up
to its reputation
first up classic Greek meze calamari
octopus and a selection of dips nice and
how the octopus cooked grilled really
does smell amazing
you can really balls up
cooking octopus but that is done
beautifully so far Caesar's cooking was
seriously good I couldn't wait to get it
stuck into my main course
shoulder of lamb beef Stefano roast
potatoes and lamb and chicken spit roast
the dishes kept on coming
delicious I mean really good that
shoulder of lamb I mean that's the cut
that a lot of chefs don't understand how
to cook she does there should be a lot
more chefs in London coming to spend a
day with this lady here to see how to
braise yeah a shoulder of lamb it will
be very honor for us we're going to be
over the moon to win it the problem I'm
faced with is the variety of restaurants
so
[Music]
the unfortunate news is and I'm really
sorry to say this because I know you
don't like taking any time out but
you're through congratulations
congratulations it tasted fantastic
really congratulations
authentic and delicious so now you have
to take another day off okay
[Music]
if you couldn't spot the chef you'd want
to meet the person because you can't
quite believe that that level of
authenticity is there so it's just the
most amazing Greek food I'm very pleased
and I will try my best to keep those 50
customers copy
from your nominations I've chosen two
extraordinary restaurants
well the f word diners prefer the
traditional Moroccan dishes Khalil
creates for his beloved restaurant Ducan
or mama zita's home cooking at the Greek
restaurant Red Cena
next on the menu is a Mediterranean
battle tonight as a fight for the last
place in the semi-final begins I feel I
feel a fight coming here from Zita
and I go Greek trying to make halloumi
cheese but with an unusual ingredient
it's so creamy
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back in London at the f word
restaurants We're Going Global in our
rest of the world category to celebrate
local restaurants serving as delicious
food from all four corners of the Earth
thanks to your nominations and months of
searching we found two exceptional
restaurants
in North London and Moroccan Dukan in
South London
sardines are very popular in both
Morocco and Greece so I've challenged
the brigades to cook their starters with
this delicious Mediterranean fish
guys it's not a race okay tonight is
about that level of excitement
consistency and make sure you're happy
with everything you send at Dukan in
South London killil's love for food
stems from his Moroccan childhood I've
always kind of embraced for those
surrounded food due to the mother that
is very very passionate about Cuisine
before we started tonight Khalil is
making sardine fritters
he makes his slice sardines with
shallots cumin lemon thyme rolls them
into balls and Fries them until golden
he says with vulgar wheat and tomato and
a green pepper dressing so killing you
come from Modern interpretation with
this round sardine dish
without actually being a really amazing
sardine it's all dark and horrible when
you do that the idea came from where
it's it's the way we've always learned
them I mean my mummy always fried them
she didn't fry them in balls necessarily
if she did them full of a butterflied
with some flour and some mola she was a
big influence on your cooking oh very
much so I mean the only influence really
nasita on New Year's Eve are you going
to put your feet up and say no more
cooking
yeah I'm not working New Year's day
how's your night off yes so that's the
only day yes
tucked away in the suburbs of North
London is red Cena a restaurant that
serves classic Greek food in a warm
friendly atmosphere they've been coming
here for 20 years
it's seen as food is all about
simplicity so tonight they're cooking
grilled sardines with Greek tomato sauce
they glaze their sardines in olive oil
and sprinkle with oregano then Grill
them on both sides and serve with salad
and a Greek tomato sauce made with
chopped tomatoes garlic coriander cumin
and paprika
you're cooking the sardines on the grill
yes
Avon so you're convinced that you're
sardine yes grilled plainly on the bone
is going to be far tastier than chickens
yes why you have to have the Born to Be
give more taste okay interesting and
what do you think yours without the bone
well it's gonna taste better
is wrong because I've got a few bits of
bones in there just to keep the flavor I
think you've missed your boats um I made
sure the little balls on the salad there
eating sardines you can accept a few
bones hid everywhere exactly
unless you're the queen mother I feel I
feel a fight coming here from Zita
takes her food very seriously but for
some Greeks it's almost a religion
traditional home-cooked food is sacred
to Greeks
and as a group of King Greek Cooks who
are about to put my skills to the test
I've been given the ultimate Challenge
to create an amazing dish for a
fantastic Greek cookbook
whether or not my recipe makes the grade
will be down to this group the
congregation from a Greek Orthodox
Church in North London
they're so passionate about Greek food
that they're putting together their own
cookbook
for the Greeks and separate foodism is
very important there is a most important
thing is their lives so we decided just
to make a book and then sell it just to
raise some money for the church as well
Nikki rossu Andreu has collected dozens
of traditional Greek recipes to ensure
they're preserved for future generations
of London Greeks and only the best will
go in her book if cotton recipes is good
enough it's going to just put in the
book otherwise it's not
I love a challenge but in order to
succeed I need to create a fantastic
dish using a classic Greek ingredient
I've chosen one that's doubled in
popularity in Britain over the past 10
years halloumi cheese and I'll be making
it from scratch now I'm taking a bit of
risk here because we're also used to
eating halloumi cheese made out of cow's
milk I'm going to push the boat out and
make mine with a hundred percent sheep's
milk
today's cow's milk is used in
mass-produced halloumi because it's
cheaper but traditionally Greek cypriots
use sheep or goat's milk because it
provides a richer flavor I want the very
best so I'll be doing the same with the
help of Dairy Farmer Kylie threadgold
so why is it that we're not actually
sort of eating and drinking more sheep's
milk a lot of people don't actually
associate sheep with milk no have you
think of a famous French cheeses we've
got rock for it's an unpasteurized
sheep's milk cheese yeah that's not a
very big teeth is it no that's what I
say it is a finger and thumb job really
to Jesus
the fat content in cheeks milk will make
my halloumi creamier and softer than
cheese made with cow's milk
I'll tell you what you make it look so
easy yeah there's an art to it isn't
there
I think she's just about empty there
going you sell that unpasteurized we do
sell it and pasteurize obviously we're
producing normally in a nice clean and
milking parlor
it's so creamy I'm incredibly creamy
that looks fantastic you know that it
does really good thick Rich creamy and
about to be turned into the most amazing
halloumi
that's harder than I thought it was
going to be thank you well done with a
churn full of the freshest cheeks milk I
leave Essex and head to West Sussex to
meet one of the only halloumi cheese
makers in the UK Mark Hardy produces
halloumi using nothing but sheep's milk
and I'm relying on his expertise to
teach me to make the very best
this is halloumi we made about three
days ago I'm dying to taste it
nice squeakiness to it sounds lovely got
really good flavor
as it breaks down the mouth there's more
creamy beautifully seasoned all the way
in was lovely really nice and deep so
that's the objective for mine to come
out as good as this one it changes I'm
sure it will
my halloumi will be made using the most
additional Greek cypriot methods never
made it before I've always been
fascinated by its texture bring the milk
up to 32 degrees and enzyme is added
called rennet and in 30 minutes it sets
the milk so it can be split into curds
and whey and the curd here that's
basically this sort of that's the
foundation of the cheese where the
cheese will come from as the curds and
whey are warmed the consistency
constantly changes looks like scrambled
egg now it doesn't look scamwork doesn't
it
the kurd is then pressed into a mold and
left to cool
the Lumi is simmered in the way for 45
minutes and is this process that stops
IT melting like other cheesies when you
cook it
so now they're floating
and that's it yep it's still quite soft
aren't they when you lift it out it
should bounce back right basically which
is what it's doing
to preserve the cheese and give the
halloumi its salty flavor it's dropped
into brine for 24 hours then it'll be
dressed with mint to enhance its flavor
now I've got to think of something
really exciting to do it justice yeah
I have a recipe in mind that will
complement the slightly salty flavor of
my handmade halloumi but would it be
good enough for Nikki's or Greek
cookbook hi
I'm very happy to be here now that look
easy oh that's good okay thank you Nikki
has sent me the challenge of coming up
with a recipe that can sit alongside
these truly authentic Greek dishes
right I've got a work cut out big time
and all I've got is this amazing
halloumi handmade so I'm gonna do salad
pan-fried scallops or some wonderful
sauteed 100 sheep's milk halloumi slice
of scallops and coat them in flour egg
and Japanese breadcrumbs get them nice
and crisp on the outside and very sort
of sweet in the middle death sweet
flavor will go brilliantly with a salty
halloumi the good thing about halloumi
made with 100 sheep's milk is it doesn't
crumble now
this of halloumi to sit on top of the
roasted scallops hot pan the halloumi is
fried alongside the scallops in olive
oil nice thing about the Lumi when you
soak it like that it doesn't melt it
doesn't disintegrate but what it does do
is get a really nice flavor a little
seasoning on the scallops
to go with the halloumi and scallops a
Capron Sultana vinaigrette simply bore
both in some salted water a little touch
of olive oil in there and a teaspoon
a white wine vinegar
then Blitz scallops onto the plate
the golden brown halloumi is then served
on the scallops with the vinaigrette
that looks amazing I hope I've done
Justice to my halloumi and more
importantly it passes the test for their
authentic Greek cookbook
all right
please take a little slice okay
you like that it's delicious really
the first and foremost important how was
the halloumi first very good halloumi
it's like the halloumi that you are
making at home and it's very very nice
really and the combination with that and
the scholarization is brilliant really
it's very good the most important
question is it going to go in the
cookbook oh yes
excellent yes
yes we wish you all the best thank you
very much indeed
it's very nice last table is a two okay
four last table yes a little white down
first so they're getting them underneath
the plates good well done that's your
last table yes yes okay down and get
ready for the main course well done
it was very tasty and the sauce was very
complimentary to the fish once you
actually managed to get it off of the
bone nice to see you both are you well
yeah very well good to see you again
what would it mean for you tonight to
walk out here as a winner oh it'll be
absolutely fantastic especially for my
mother all the years that she's worked
in the kitchens and one way another
it'll be fantastic extraordinary woman
that is so passionate hasn't taken a
whole day in two years where's he gonna
retire I'll be doing it for years the
reason I bought this big restaurant
overall was so to calm down a bit relax
a bit but you could do a deal with it
promise of the shave properly and then
she could retire no maybe maybe yes I
will go on it yes
thank you mate take care bye-bye it
didn't have much Taste and to be honest
when you see a sardine you expect it to
be like a sardine nice and fresh and
grilled not mess around like that
Isabella nice to see you nice to see you
hi wise welcome to the airport how are
you very excited yeah
in action how does it make you feel well
it's normally like that it's a bit
stressed today but uh I'm sure he's
enjoying himself yeah do you think he's
gonna win tonight well I really hope so
because he's so passionate and he really
cooks with his heart so yeah nice to see
hope you enjoying my courses
right retina's simply grilled sardine
hopefully they'll just flake off the
bone nicely yeah beautiful
touch of the sauce
flavor delicious seasoned beautifully
and it just Falls away from the bone
delicious really good now do can it
looks like a plate of Meatballs on
couscous
he left his skin on which is a bit
disturbing does it deliver in flavor
it's quite mushy and Flowery inside and
it doesn't actually taste much of a
sardine it's a clear winner for me
definitely red seen as Char grilled
sardine simply done tasting delicious no
fuss
if the Donnas don't like their starters
they don't pay the results are in thank
you
so duka let's start off with you first
yes
the number of customers
they're happy to pay
for their starter out of 25 is
congratulations
[Applause]
what are they like Debbie
um great presentation great presentation
clearly and a great existing source as
well 21 out of 25 great start thank you
really well done yes
okay
let's see now the number of customers
that are happy to pay for your sardine
out of 25 is
23 out of 25. well done that's
incredible
that is a great start thank you for
everybody what do we like before that
the the fish at a Great Smoky flavor and
the sauce complement very well the fish
as well thank you to everybody thank you
two very very good starts 21 out of 25
23 out of 25 there's only two points in
it and there's 50 main courses each
great start clear down yeah let's
concentrate on the main course well done
[Applause]
[Music]
now frustration is going to cook their
main course first up Dukan
do consider dish tonight is King prawn
and muscle tagine
I'll take a couple of peppers from there
and it'll start by making charmulla
paste with chopped coriander sliced
garlic salt cumin paprika and lemon
juice
he adds finely chopped preserved lemons
and mixes with olive oil to make a paste
he puts the sharmula into a sizzling pan
generally spoons there and add King
prawns and Harissa this beautiful smell
really really beautiful smell the adds
chopped roasted red peppers mussels and
covers really mostly what I'm trying to
get there is the flavor and the color
for the dish then add sliced potatoes
and simmers
serves in a tagine pot and garnishes
with grilled lemon and coriander
King prawn and muscle tagine
served
what's so special about this tagine is a
very well known Moroccan marinade and
how successful is this tagine with the
prawns and mussels been in the
restaurant this is very successful
actually I mean I've got people coming
particularly just for this dish so where
did you learn to cook I learned for very
very young age are you like to be in the
kitchen with my mother
at Greek restaurant Rosina head chef
zeta's menu is inspired by recipes she
learned from her mother
[Music]
retina signature dish tonight is a Greek
mixed grill
for the Chicken Kebabs Cedar cubes are
chicken breast she then coats the
chicken with a marinade of oregano Greek
yogurt pepper puree crushed garlic lemon
juice and olive oil I make it taste and
moist not to get dry because always the
best the chicken if you're not very
careful it's very dry for the lamb
kebabs Zeta marinades cubes of lamb in
Pepper puree lemon juice and oregano
next you chops onion and tomato for the
kebabs then grills and base with olive
oil and lemon juice oregano salt and
pepper
then she grills the lamb cutlets and
finally Cedar grills are calves liver
then Place everything up with fresh
tasiki tabouli some rocket leaves and a
wedge of lemon
francina's Greek mixed grill served
once you think the designers will be
excited about this it's very juicy very
tasty very nice now your son says that
if you win tonight he's going to shave
yes that stupid beard off I've got a
sharp knife oh my gosh
if you win tonight it's coming off
that's the good that's it good news
we have to do it we definitely and guys
remember yeah every table has to go out
like the first Tower yeah with that
level of exact Perfection yeah
absolutely good now for some festive pie
filling Moroccan Style
traditional British mince pies have been
around for centuries they used to be
filled with fruit real mince meat and
spices brought back from the Middle East
during the Crusades over time the meat
has given way to the fruit and spices
they still do something similar in
Morocco but it's called pastilla
but Moroccans use a meat seldom seen on
British menus pigeon
[Music]
to send on a taste test they're my
favorite old London bird Janet Street
Porter most people think of pigeons is
nasty bourbon I wouldn't dream of eating
them it's not surprising is it the
scruffy feral pigeons we see in our
cities hardly look appetizing I wouldn't
even think about eating them pigeons is
found us okay so flying rats don't
exactly get you going but wood pigeon
the feral pigeons clean Living Country
cousin might in Morocco they absolutely
love it now I love Moroccan food and I
think they've got exactly the right idea
when it comes to making pigeons tasty
wood pigeon is on the menu of one of the
finest Moroccan restaurants in the UK
Momo in central London I'm here to meet
executive chef Muhammad urad
[Music]
wood pigeon is prized for its Rich red
meat but you'll probably need to order
it from your local butcher okay so
they're not scummy they're not flying
rides that's very good they're not blind
rats that is a free range wood pigeon
that looks absolutely delicious Muhammad
is going to be showing me a classic
Moroccan dish that you can do at home
pastillas with a pigeon filling tell me
what it is it's a fight it's a pie with
this very complicated filo paste exactly
first The Filling Muhammad fries finely
diced onions in butter how many of these
do you make in a week
30 a day next we take the breast meat
off the bone and add the carcasses to
the onions Moroccan Cuisine is all about
spices scents and colors so we also add
chopped coriander and sliced Ginger five
sticks of cinnamon in bush bush and a
pinch of saffron
[Applause]
[Music]
at least two okay great the pigeon
breasts are coated in olive oil seasoned
and seared in a separate pan we remove
the carcasses and cinnamon sticks and
add sugar it smells delicious sugar
helps to create that mouthful tring
Moroccan mix of sweet and savory flavors
that reminds me of Christmas as the
filling mixture reduces we dice the
pigeon breast
two beaten eggs are added to thicken and
bind the filling mix we add an extra
sprinkle of cinnamon and the pigeon meat
goes in it's an unusual combination of
smells it's very very unusual The
pastilla Filling is now ready no finish
brush the edge of a sheet of filo pastry
with egg whites place the pigeon meat
filling in the center and top with roast
almonds fold the pastry so it's like a
very
sophisticated piece of origami wrap a
second sheet around the pastilla and
stick down with egg whites
I go in yeah try to no no no no no no
don't worry okay I think what I really
like about Moroccan food is combining
meat with sweet things it's just
Fantastic look at that we glaze the
pastillas with butter and stick them in
a hot oven for five minutes
hello look fantastic that's my one and
that's your one finally we dust them
with icing sugar and finish with
cinnamon
truly Moorish
it's delicious it is it's the
combination of sugar and meat together
right I'm going to take mine for Gordon
right it was a nice hugging you it's a
good life thank you
[Music]
honey you look great thank you I'm
rocking machine in the house tonight yes
you've also been cooking I spotted
Moroccan Cuisine today and learn how to
cook a pastilla amazing so this is
Pigeon yeah
because it's meat sugar and eggs
together that's delicious in filo pastry
but it's delicious really good indeed
now they're not the sort of average
pigeon that fly over Nelson's column
these are wood pigeons they're wood
pigeons and they're very Plum when you
cook pigeons overcooked within seconds
that is moist delicious slightly gamey
but sweet what you're supposed to say
right if you don't mind me please
Janet what a beautiful pie you made with
that feeling tasting folding it around
your meat no you just mashed it up
beforehand it was it's like origami
really well done you can see
make them perfect guys yeah well done
thank you
really well done well done everybody
yeah job well done thank you the meat
was all cooked Perfection
um I thought it went really well with
the satsiki and the tabouli it was
really nice actually
only thing that led it down was the
prawns they were slightly overdone um
but the presentation was fantastic
lifting off the lid was really good
right I've been dying to taste these um
it seems grill lamb
nice Beauty cooked
and
that's delicious again simply done
briefly Char grilled chicken marinated
with the pepper and the onions
yeah I mean the whole thing looks simple
but the most important thing about this
is getting every little component right
on the half
Duke
uh awkward muscles in the Shell prawns
with the heads on and then potato in the
bottom
so
corn slightly rubbery it's a great shame
and when they're bright white like that
inside it's it's a sign of the prawn
actually being so overcooked potato at
the bottom
that's really weird
because potatoes rock hard
overcooked prawn and a slightly
undercooked potato what a shame I hope
the diners didn't get what I got
so it was up to me definitely the mixed
drill the boats have been counted and
the results are in right
it was also the main course uh JB please
a good luck to all four of you uh right
uh
so the number of customers they're happy
to pay for your mixed grill out of 50 is
well done 37 out of 50.
and before the meat was delicious yes
and itzaki was full of flavor and the
13th I didn't pay what do they say the
liver of the cooked and the veg
undercooked and the veg on the skewer
undercooked yeah okay
right Kelly
the number of customers are happy to pay
out of 50 for your tagine
is
19 out of 50.
what went wrong
prawns overcooked the potato undercooked
as a cake in the balls you can pull this
back do not give up okay thank you yeah
next on the menu can Duke and snatch
Victory from Red Cena someone always
deserves to be absolutely perfect yes
day day for the meat that Janet's been
preparing for next week's Grand Final
I'm sorry because you've been good fun
but you're gonna make the most fantastic
meat
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back the diners are sitting in
judgment on two brigades who are
determined to make it through to next
week's semi-finals
and if they make it all the way to the
Grand Final they'll be cooking with meat
provided by Janet from her Farm in
Yorkshire
[Music]
this series I've asked Janet to provide
the meat for the F word's best local
restaurant competition final
loving lazy birds get off your asses
along the way she picked up a few prizes
of her own
both her Dexter cattle and a mangle it's
a pigs one rosette to the prestigious
nitterdale show
oh my word
faster a sure sign of the quality we can
expect in the f word kitchen
Janet's Dexter steers and igsworth
poultry have already gone for Slaughter
but the three porkers have clearly got
under her skin and Janet's face with the
hardest farewell of all
right guys I've got
it's
off to the slaughterhouse for you
I'm sorry because you've been good fun
and you've got great personalities
but you're gonna make the most fantastic
meat I know that
if you want one last game of football
should we just have one last guy
I'll be in golf come on pass
pass it come on pass
they will make the most brilliant me I
know that and they've really fattened up
well
they're really happy animals so I don't
feel that bad about them going to the
slaughter
yeah right very good
Angelic takes the pigs on their final
Journey
biggest personalities and they've been a
real pleasure to be around on the other
hand they're never going to be pets
there were always being bred for food
and I think they've had a terrific life
hello Janet hi Martin oh terrible
weather beautiful weather
Slaughter man Martin McIntyre leads the
pigs to a temporary pen
this brief respite allows the pigs to
relax and is called lairage nice piece
I don't want the last time they see me
to be wearing looking like this
the pigs will be slaughtered as humanely
as possible so before they're killed
they'll be stunned
electrical tongs past 240 volts through
the pig knocking it out they'll know and
feel nothing
the pig's Throne must be cut within 15
seconds of stunning to ensure an
absolutely painless end I mean it's hard
to watch
not a thing
the pig now dead its carcass goes into
hot water tank to get rid of its
extraordinary wiry hair they alert Janet
like a baby's
birthday
and inspector from the meat hygiene
service monitors a Slaughter process to
make sure all the meat and awful is fit
for human consumption
the pig is then gutted and his organs
inspected
all right before they can pass into the
food supply chain
next she inspects the carcass
get your stamp on it then
finally the carcass is split and hung in
the chiller ready for shipping pork
should hang for two to three days for
its best flavor
back at her small holding Janet has time
to reflect on a once in a lifetime
farming experience
I'm off the room wow I think I took to
ok so I'll miss the pigs eggs worth
chickens Dexter cattle mangalitza pigs
the two restaurants lucky enough to go
through to next week's final are sure to
have some fantastic meat to cook with
for the dessert the brigades are cooking
my recipe for apple cake which is
inspired by the sweet and spicy flavors
of Morocco and Greece
spiced apple cake aromatic and really
easy to make first off start preparing
the apples hot pan butter apples chop
cinnamon powder
honey that starts to get the apples
really nice and caramelized then add
dates
orange zest
and Spoon into baking dishes
for the sponge topping sift 125 grams of
plain flour add a pinch of salt caster
sugar
baking powder butter
and Blitz
and what you're looking for is this
really nice soft breadcrumb texture then
add orange zest and mix in beaten egg
milk and vanilla extract
Boon onto the spiced apples
sprinkle with flaked almonds
and bake for around 18 minutes
so they're icing sugar and finish with
vanilla ice cream
spiced apple cake done
someone always deserves to be absolutely
perfect yes this is my recipe and
there's no excuse on this one yeah the
cigarettes in the caramelization of the
apples yes add the dates season the
cinnamon glaze with the honey do you
wish you were grilling the apples on the
grill or you're happy to do this in a
pan yeah
let's go guys ice cream's melting let's
go it should be melting in front of the
customer wait yeah not in front of us
tonight I'm going up against cold feet
star Faye Ripley if she loses the
challenge tonight she promises to eat
this little baby here
a plate of cold feet
you're gonna have to win they're
definitely gonna have to win yeah
good cooking
my break your diet brownies how are you
looking brownies yeah so I'm going to
make my favorite recipe chocolate
brownies confidence I'm aware of the
fact that I don't have any Michelin
stars if I beat you yes it would be the
greatest achievement of my life I'm
going to include the birth of my two
children is that wrong I feel very
honored to hear that now is that slow
motion whisk in there what is that my
sugar and my eggs this is enough Gordon
I don't need to show off this is my
equipment practice this is very much
Back to Basics over here in a minute
when that's cool down I'm going to just
combine that just fold that in there
what are you doing okay in here my band
Maria got my butter and my chocolate
melting nice and slowly yes okay and
then eggs vanilla sugar in I'm gonna go
for some electricity so excuse me why I
have a quick whisk go on
um now you were 30 when you got your big
break on cold feet and grip the nation
yes I think and quite moving as well
quite emotional it had a massive effect
on my career and my life that show it
had a good old combo didn't it yeah
people still sort of are going this down
about it and they're sweet you know
people still talk about it to me in the
streets and stuff now your husband's
Australian yeah yes and he's a lot
younger than you does that make you a
cougar
that much younger than four years in
men's terms is yeah my wife thinks he's
quite hot he is quite hot yes yes your
husband did a an amazing naked scene in
mural's wedding yes my husband gets to
often be naked on screen do you know he
had his lips around Emmanuel bayard's
nipple one he was it's just what you do
know it's what you go to work
you stuck someone's nipple it's what you
have to do he gets to have sex on screen
with loads of really beautiful women I
get John Thompson
twice would you ever do a naked scene I
don't think anyone would want to see it
to be honest I was going to pay money
perhaps in a light comedy they might now
you're copying me because everything I
do okay from adding me what do you mean
I'm copying you stop copying stop
copying embarrassing no melted the
chocolate with a butter over a bat
marine and then folded in the cocoa
powder and the flour and then broke
through these really nice little lumps
of milk chocolate dark chocolate and
white chocolate throughout the mix quite
dense so it's going to melt and cook at
the same time
Facebook paper at the bottom yeah stop
it from sticking and then straight in
yeah time to find out what the blind
tasters make of the brownies let's place
up look at that baby
whatever okay let's go side by side look
at that that's really good right where
is he my little French fighter pilot off
you go stick with me kids don't forget I
pay your salary let's go but I might do
one day hello
it's very crumbly isn't it very very
light very dry but it's quite nice it's
too sticky it's not sweet and bitter
which is nice okay
it's caramelized almost this one's a
little bit sweeter as well you can
charge my life the texture holds up
better just be on the outside then soft
in the middle right quite the compliment
you are right JB results oh no he's got
that smoke on his face I don't like it
right how do they go down human gray one
what was the score first
um four to one four to one yeah
four one to who
oh no
no I'm gonna punch the air
you're joking on you four one yeah so
the Michelin stars what do they like
mine
um it wasn't cooked enough wasn't cooked
enough Yes mine was perfect soft and
gooey in the center crisp on the outside
actually two gooey yeah four one I can't
believe you beat me four one four one
I'll send you the recipe bye babes thank
you
damn
for the place in the semi-finals at
stake everything rests on this last
course come on you can pull this back
yes yes now it's about reputation what
are you stand for what do you believe in
yeah and why you decide to open that
restaurant absolutely okay absolutely
don't let one dish yeah put you off yes
it's a kick in the Box clearly however
you can pull it back yeah thank you Chef
yep and Sita yeah it's a fat lady sings
no no no no no no no
I'm not saying absolutely yes it's not
over yes no it's not over yet
Victory could be the beginning of
something really special for Khalil well
when in the the competition would
definitely change my life and if we're
seeing a win tonight it'll be an
outstanding achievement for 63 year old
Zita
competition for us
what did the diners make of the brigades
dessert
it was beautiful a lot of cinnamon
perfect
massive enough to film with her too
I thought it was against these nuts
they're nicely spiced lots of cinnamon
really good nicer flavor to that right
dessert
Cena's the secret behind this dessert is
the cooking the apples to begin with
um
that's delicious
not overcooked not undercooked and just
really nice and moist it doesn't stick
to the roof of your mouth beautifully
done
nice
lovely color on the apples
nice and fragrant with the orange
running through and a really nice
generous canonization on the apples with
the honey delicious between the two of
them it's a tough call because they both
taste delicious it is my recipe however
I think the slight Edge goes to dukem
because they've got that real nice
flavor in the apples
with the last semi-final place up for
grabs the fate of the brigades is in the
hands of the Diners right JB results
please
Duncan
go start with you
now the number of customers that are
happy to pay for your desserts out of 25
is
that
is amazing 23 out of 25 well done
[Applause]
right red Xena that means you need four
or more out of 25 for your dessert to
win tonight but that's not the only
Target because
only the top six the top highest scoring
restaurants on the leaderboard go
through to the semi-final
so to get in to the top six
you need to get 15 out of 25 or more
that's how tight it is
very tight okay the number
of customers
that are happy to pay for dessert out of
bearing in mind what's at stake
is
17 out of 25 well done yes
that's amazing
congratulations
[Applause]
every point you earn well done brought
on racing nights yeah really seriously
well done
restaurant so everybody is coming and
they will see how proud I am
so Rosina cleans the final spot in the
semi-finals
they'll be joining my best Indian
Chinese Thai Argentinian and British
restaurants
[Music]
welcome to the final week of my
competition to find the F word's best
local restaurants
it started with nearly 10 000
nominations and from these 18
outstanding restaurants made it through
to compete in the f word kitchen
now only six remain in the competition
in tonight's semi-final three great
restaurants go head-to-head and I'll
pick just one of them to go through the
Grand Final on Thursday
thinking tonight my first semi-final are
my best local Indian restaurant lassan
Sweet Mandarin who won the Chinese
Trophy and my best local Argentine
restaurant Santa Maria Del Sur three
restaurants and I've got three extreme
challenges to test them to the absolute
limit we haven't slept for the last few
days getting uh very very very nervous
now how are you well very nearer waiting
for you for the answer or were the
opponents but only one can stay in the
competition
[Music]
you deserve to go through to the final
I've devised three daunting tests I've
only got an hour to eat is that gonna be
okay
first up my team of secret diners film
undercover for me after which I
eliminate one of the restaurants
the f word secret diners were somewhat
let down
then the competition heats up in the
second test as I hit the restaurants
with 30 demanding f word diners
[Music]
and the third and final challenge
took up my Flagship three-star
restaurant in London who goes home and
who makes it through to the final
tonight I decide they're cooking one
dish the most important dish of their
entire lives
father
tonight I'm taking the f word on the
road because it's the last week of my
competition to find the F word's best
local restaurants
on tonight's first semi-final Santa
Maria Del Sur La San and Sweet Mandarin
all Extraordinary contenders
at lassan in Birmingham I sampled some
of the most Sublime Curry I've had
outside India that's exquisitely
presented finesse but actor Islam was
cocky and argumentative it had nothing
to do with flavor well I mean ultimately
it's edible and it will add to it but
it's not the core of it if you move it
away you're not going to lose anything
the only thing to match is immense ego
was his talent I'm looking forward to
lifting that trophy in contrast at Santa
Maria Del Sur I was bowled over by the
warmth and charm of manager Jose Jose
and the passion of head chef Ernesto and
I've tasted some of the best steak I've
ever eaten
they're amazing I mean really good
and Sweet Mandarin in Manchester served
up some stunning authentic Chinese
cuisine it's a fabulous family business
run by twin sisters
[Laughter]
I've got to pick the very best
restaurant how by setting them all three
very tough challenges
for the first test I've hired a team of
food experts to work undercover for me
as secret diners good evening have a
reservation under the name of Duncan
it's a trick of the restaurant trade I
use all the time I spend a fortune on
secret diners coming to all my
restaurants it's a really good way to
see how consistent a Russian is on a
daily basis can I have the
lamb I'm sending my secret diners to all
three restaurants who have no idea
they've been filmed
oh
I have to find out how the Russians
perform when they're not in the
spotlight and their guard is down
whichever restaurant fails to impress me
on this test will be eliminated
asan
this stylish Urban restaurant Prides
itself on Cutting Edge and contemporary
cuisine
I thought the food was fantastic but the
service was slow
I hope my secret Diner is taken care of
today by the staff
hey blind one to go undercover today
because she's an experienced food editor
[Music]
so he sits down the gentleman and lets
the lady sit down on her own
[Music]
to grab somebody or if they are they're
collecting plates
I've told Kate drank like a very fussy
diner with delicate taste buds
is it possible to change it because it's
a bit too hot for me sorry I could do
with a little bit more of a smile on
there not look so miserable
oh thank you
finally smile should be at the beginning
not at the end very sweet of him
actually said if I don't like this one
here I'll place it again so that's
really good the only thing I could be
worried about with lassan service that
was attentive halfway through not at the
very beginning it's a little bit
fragmented and service needs to gel next
up sweet mandarini Manchester's Northern
quarter
the express lunch looks like it's really
good value it's run by twins who are the
third generation of women in a Chinese
cooking Dynasty established by their
grandmother
[Music]
the sisters don't have a clue that
they're going to be assessed by my
undercover Observer
[Music]
I've hired Cheryl farmer because she's
got nearly 20 years experience in the
food industry and have instructed her to
order off the menu to see the chef is
willing to be flexible
do you do a split
Twitter
without the batter
is that possible that kind of thing
thank you
it's definitely one of the owners
essentially because
thank you
food sort of heaped and dumped on a
plate no finesse
yeah
it's nice but it's just not hot here but
like I like my food really hiking hot
I'm trying to get retention but the
waitress has rounded up to a massive eye
shots
[Music]
in fact the restaurant's been abandoned
by our staff I think
the one positive part is that it's run
by two sisters and they're great girls
they're warm they're funny and they're
charismatic but theirs must have been an
off day when a restaurant's family run
then it needs to feel family run they
need to be a lot more friendlier so will
Santa Maria Del Sur do any better
open five years ago Santa Maria is
vibrant and Lively the restaurant
radiates warmth and friendliness
[Music]
secret Diner is on the way and the
fun-loving Brigade from Battersea
have no idea
[Music]
I've only got an hour to eat is that
okay is that gonna be okay
Rob Allison regularly works on
best-selling recipe books it's a bit
lighter here really yeah it lights and I
actually um
hmm I'd say that the filling could do
with a bit of seasoning but um
pastry is spot on there absolute spot on
literally we're just halfway through our
starters and they've just started liking
candles and I think they're like yeah is
that the lights going down yeah the
lights going down a little bit if you're
open at 6 30 then you have to be ready
at 6 15. so the minute that first
customer walks through everything's
there candles are there Muses the
atmosphere smell of the grills there pay
for my main course I'll have I'm gonna
go vegetarian I'm afraid I'm gonna go
with the mushrooms
I've asked Rob to be deliberately
indecisive to see how the team cope
you know what yeah I'm gonna be really
annoying I've just seen my friend's
steaks I really want a steak
is that okay
you're an absolutely thank you so much
thank you very much they have dealt with
that
impeccably I would have actually
probably kicked my own head in had I
done that slightly slow start picked up
in the middle and then when he changed
his mind about the dish they really
warmed him in a big way so yeah great
comeback
so it's time to eliminate one of the
restaurants
my decision is based on everything I've
seen and learned so far include nails of
invaluable undercover evidence
[Music]
no one has any idea I've been spying on
them
but I have told them that one restaurant
is about to be knocked out of the
competition
[Music]
just it's just reached the top and it's
just stopped for a second doesn't it and
it's that feeling and it's been going on
for about a week now so I do want the
ride to carry on we haven't slept for
the last few days just being very
nervous waiting for today it's important
result for my life for my for my
restaurant and for Cynthia as well for
everyone you know
[Music]
hi Jose's Gordon how are you oh very
nervous man very nervous waiting for you
for the answer now the secret of any
good local restaurant is attentive
service good food recently
diners in the Santa Maria restaurant on
the on the feedback and the insight to
what the f word secret diners gave me in
terms of their experience
yes
Santa Maria
oh my God
congratulations really well done well
done
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
it's great something amazing for me
my boss Cynthia my little one every
every everyone is happy today I think
it's one of the most important moments
of my life
the Maria have done amazingly well and
now they have a chance to win a place in
the final
gracias
who will also be joining Santa Maria in
the final stage of the competition
lassan from Birmingham afternoon
speaking I might help you
I was wondering or Sweet Mandarin from
Manchester congratulations well done
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back it's a semi-final my best
local restaurant competition and three
teams are fighting for place in the
final only one will go through so far in
tonight's first semi-final my best local
Indian Chinese and Argentinian
restaurants have been put to the test
team of secret diners to investigate the
contenders
there's so many waiters around so it's
quite hard to grab somebody and Santa
Maria passed with flying colors they're
still in the running congratulations
really well done
but now I have to eliminate one of the
remaining two restaurants
we're going out of the competition La
San or Sweet Mandarin
every call I think everyone's just gonna
be looking at the phone today is very
important for us it really is the make
or break
good afternoon lassan Java speaking I
might help you hello it's wondering
secret diners in the dining room at
listen I've had the f word secret diners
and eating a Sweet Mandarin recently
I've learned a hell of a lot and I've
seen some fascinating things the
feedback's been extraordinary the value
of the set lunch menu
um is amazing what if I like your
confidence there's a Cockiness that has
to be contained
so
the name of the game is consistency and
that has to be so apparent across the
board
[Music]
foreign
secret diners uh were somewhat let down
the food wasn't up to scratch there was
also a complaints in terms of servers
being uninterested so I'm really sorry
thank you ladies of course we're
disappointed because we've gone so far
into the competition you're going to
lose in life don't you
oh well winner because we have won the
best Chinese restaurants you know what I
mean
son
really good fantastic work great
feedback from the secret diners
incredibly happy very consistent
congratulations
[Applause]
never experienced anything like this
it's just absolutely amazing I mean the
feeling is is definitely there now
obviously with Raffles from my cocky uh
nachos you know it's just the way it is
so I've chosen Santa Maria from South
London to fight it out with lasan from
Birmingham to be worthy of a place in
the final they have to survive two more
challenges
[Music]
[Applause]
first I've asked 30 f word diners to
Tesla San and Santa Maria to Breaking
Point
and I'm going to judge both restaurants
perform us more critically than ever
before
[Applause]
we're going to have lunch at La San and
then dinner at Santa Maria
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good morning to see
you you're gonna be my eyes and ears
across the whole dining room your
experience is going to help me judge
which restaurants go through to the
final of the F word's best local
restaurant
under intense pressure I'm going to
watch like a hawk front a house and
behind the scenes in the kitchen
and something that we're you know we're
working every day and food that we do
all the time so you know nothing's alien
to us I think it'll be good
[Applause]
hi guys ladies how are you well I'm very
well Chef how are you yeah everyone did
thank you good to see you right this is
it real pressure you perform brilliantly
in the f word restaurants now I want to
see what you like in your own restaurant
under immense pressure two hours two
courses 30 diners yes it's not just the
food the service have you got what it
takes to get into the final yeah this
today okay will help me judge you guys
Under Pressure I'll be Upstairs
Downstairs in and out in and out good
luck thank you two hours starting from
now off you go guys yes
I know this is every restaurant's worst
nightmare 30 diners arriving all at once
but I need to test the team to the Limit
if act hourly staff support each other
today it should run like Club work
but I can tell straight away that the
audience system is far too complicated
so each waiter takes an order then puts
in the computer
just forwards you back two times you
will enter the order so that's very
difficult isn't it because if he's
entering the computer
I'm now taking the order if he makes a
mistake then there's already going to
two different people before you get to
the kitchen
the orders taken by the waiters are
given to the major D who puts them into
the computer in the dining room upstairs
then they're supposed to be printed out
in the kitchen which is downstairs
okay gentlemen here it goes you've got
one lemon Soul one Afghani lamb get the
lamb straight away please lemon so I'll
hold that back for a second we've got
two horses missing on table 11's order
complicated audience system they take
the order then it goes into another
waiter's hand yeah another goes to the
computer you just said there's tomb
calls he's missing why doesn't one
waiter take an order come to the
computer complete it without passing on
to somebody else
the reason why I'm in the I'm in the
ordering system the we've got quite an
old system just to make your life easier
so I'm just asking from a chef's point
of view if I don't feel comfortable I
come down and ask you and I want to know
your reason that's all of course not
cool
with 30 customers to look after at the
same time actar's ordering system can't
cope and my diners are now eating
different courses it looks bad for
customers eating their main course when
other cousins haven't had their starter
for me operation I was not all a la
carte so don't [__] me that way what
I'm trying to say is that if I'm sat
here and I'm waiting for my starter and
I'm still waiting for my starter and
then the next table's main course has
come I'm going to feel a little bit
pissed off that's what I'm trying to
tell you okay don't waffle me yes thank
you and the waiting times are just far
too long how long have you waiting for
your main courses you only shared a
starter yeah how long have you waiting
for the main courses
yeah yeah I've got it down to 35 minutes
35 minutes is far too long okay thank
you uh how long for their main course
please I think the customers need to
know
after
60 remembers how much longer if you give
me a time
[Music]
please actor he's Gotta Get a Grip get
hold of the Rings and really sort of
start pushing these two down but you
know kitchens just don't run normally
they need generating you've got to push
them all the time so there's a customer
sat upstairs
minus the main course which is not good
enough
when our task food does make it to my
diners they think it's absolutely
delicious
a lot of really powerful flavors going
on so it's good
but the curry isn't everyone's taste
did the customer say anything when we
clear this away customers are finding
the sauce a bit too much sometimes okay
is anyone telling the chef I think the
chef says that has a significance so he
kills initial I know it's a signature
dish it doesn't stop him from making it
less spicy does it it doesn't know it's
like everyone's scared to tell the chef
what's happening does anyone give
constructive feedback to the chef
downstairs or not no
if this was my restaurant okay I'd be
deeply concerned that food like that is
coming back why is that not eaten and
why is all this sauce still there is
there an issue customers not happy
surely you'd want to know
yes that's all this is a signature dish
this is something that means a lot to
the restaurant yet no one's saying
anything
the waiters can't give actor honors
feedback on his dishes that's a serious
problem
hi guitars Gordon
social
the uh mugmani sauce that they're saying
that they're saying it's a little bit
too spicy okay with the reference to the
monkey
because if you believe it it's a Night
Like This
is I mean it's we serve it a lot yeah
okay now I appreciate that there's only
two tables that's all just a touch of
yoga but there's another table that have
been cleared and two-thirds of the dish
hasn't been eaten so
it's not as if it's 120 people sat up
here
the food in the restaurants
I think I've you know definitely come
back and give it another try
so my 30 diners definitely enjoyed their
lunch but there is room for improvements
right uh well done I tasted every dish
I thought the food was outstanding
chef
absolutely delicious
sorry
sorry however when customers don't
finish
two-thirds of their plate I think you
should see what's going on I don't think
food should just be washed down to the
bin and plates stuck in the dishwasher I
think that should come back down to the
kitchen because that gives you feedback
we started off good in the kitchen but
upstairs was somewhat at many stages
embarrassing the service was erratic
order's been taken main course has been
missed off I'm looking for a restaurant
to win
the F word's best local ration on an
overall experience
I thought the food was delicious I
thought the service was mediocre
oh
right now you know
um
we'll see a bit disappointed that you
know we didn't uh you know Delight Chef
Ramsay on all all points of dining
experience could have been better but
you know the fact is you know we've made
it so far and he did say he's got
something up his sleeve for the next
challenge so I'm looking forward to that
now
[Music]
next stop dinner at the Argentine Grill
House in South London
when I first visited Santa Maria they
sent me some of the best steak I've ever
had
so I hope even under pressure from my 30
f word diners round two here we go
they're going to maintain their
excellent standards and and yes Ryan
Davis and I
started coming
really soon I'm always trying to relax
Kim because he's nervous
how are you you're right fine thank you
this is gonna be a big test on tonight
30 diners arriving all at the same time
will they manage on the grill will they
manage the service will it be fast slow
I want to see what they're like with me
watching them in their own environment
good to see you guys yeah and first of
all congratulations really well done now
is where it really is going to be
immense pressure now real diners in your
restaurant yeah that really know their
food so I want to see it running under
immense pressure like a normal fully
booked restaurant yeah make sure that
everything you send out the kitchen
you're 100 happy with because they are
critical okay two hours
start from now good luck
I remember it's not a racer who's
cooking in the kitchen just two of you
yesterday wow yeah come on
okay we have one of the first tables
table number three one more room one
Freeland
and two during
Santa Maria are quick Off the Mark but
the starters are all going out at once
they need to stagger the orders and Pace
themselves you normally send the
starters that quickly you don't wait
till your steaks are on first before you
send the start or you just send the
salad straight away okay because they're
quite thick though it's fillet yes
they've only been here literally 50
minutes first order taking within five
minutes I'm Ready the food's coming out
good start very good start my big worry
if Ernesto gets 30 different steaks on
that Grill going away at all the same
time different temperatures rare medium
medium well that's gonna be a big test
for him in about 45 minutes time I hope
he doesn't crack
so far my dinos are having a lovely time
just from sort of the first moment we've
walked in a really really friendly staff
the waiters came over introduced
themselves they've chatted to us they've
you know had a bit of a laugh with us
but having served the starter
simultaneously
Ernesto is now Under Pressure to have 30
main courses ready exactly the same time
as well
yes surely it may cause you serve at the
same time they're not eating that's all
they're leaving it good to go cold
sorry for the slightly today guys it's
coming the stick right now no problem
hopefully we will make it up with the
steak
there's not such a long gap between the
main course and the stuff yeah that's it
thank you thank you that's a good point
to speak afterwards
let me speak with you guys
so that's high and it's electric which
is great sounds brilliant but they just
shouldn't rush food out there take their
time pace yourself a little bit more
stop very quickly within a few moments
um following out after 5-10 minutes the
main course
I'm very very fast
as if they want to turn the tables for
another person
that's really good
yeah that is awesome we've all been here
just over an hour and already the last
orders have been cooked
it's the last one yes it's the last one
medium rare medium rare
[Music]
the team have worked so well together
that they've finished with 40 minutes
left on the clock
it was it was really really good very
enjoyable good taste it was uh perfect
and absolutely melted in your mouth it's
probably the best steak I've ever tasted
actually I had fillet steak as my main
course which was absolutely superb I
can't fault it at all okay right
first of all well done I thought you
handled it very well I thought the food
you know looked and tasted Immaculate I
thought the service was very friendly
and very Charming yeah if there's one
criticism tonight it's not a race you
finished with just over 40 minutes left
there's only 30 customers in there not
130 customers and every table yeah it's
a value table they're here for an
experience the overall package don't
rush
thank you
[Music]
we tried to make a great job tonight
with with love
the passion try to make wonderful for
tonight Santa Maria Grill is gonna be a
tough one to beat because that's a whole
package there and it's it's done to
perfection watching Ernesto work on that
Grill I mean it's amazing I mean talk
about multitask it's like an octopus
with like 10 arms and more importantly
above everything everything they touch
is about passion
thank you
for the day of extraordinary dining at
two incredible restaurants but one of
them will be eliminated
the biggest test is still in front of
them who's going through the final right
now I haven't got a clue
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the F worth lesson and
Santa Maria are fighting out for a place
in the final tonight two semi-finalists
have already faced two daunting tests
under pressure in their own restaurants
I'm seeing their true colors
29 year old actor has proved Fearless in
the kitchen one lemon song One Afghani
lamb get the lamb straight away please
lemon so hold that back for a second
pushes Colony boundaries and lassan's
original distinctive menu reflects his
passion for Innovation I thought the
food was outstanding but he risk over
complicating the food
you're playing too hard he has an
extraordinary potential but he won't
listen to advice even from me if I don't
feel comfortable I come down and ask you
and I want to know your reason that's
all so misses out on vital feedback
at Santa Maria
Ernesto La Brava is a master of his
charcoal grill okay we have one of the
first table table number three
times each day to Perfection and that
takes Talent above everything everything
they touch is about passion and I'm
worried that the menu and a nested
repertoire is a bit limited he cooks
sublimely within his comfort zone and
I'm already impressed but to earn a
place in the final he has to dazzle me
now both restaurants face the ultimate
Challenge here at my own Flagship
Restaurant Royal Hospital Road in London
Acton Ernesto must create and serve
Exquisite Cuisine worthy of a place on
the menu at my three Mission star
restaurants
[Music]
their entire lives and with that one
dish they've got one final chance to
prove themselves I am very very nervous
to cook in this restaurant because it's
the restaurant of
one of the best Japan in the world
cooking at Chef Francis restaurant
through michelin's time and something
that I've always aspired to you know
never mind three one would do for me and
I'm cooking the three original Style
Kitchen today
[Music]
I've worked for over 10 years to build
raw Hospital roads reputation and
tonight I'm putting it on the line
I've invited some highly distinguished
guests including Angela Hartnett one of
the only female chefs in Britain ever to
be warded a Michelin star
is a huge challenge for these guys to be
cooking in this three-star restaurant
and then they've got Gorda bearing down
on them so they're probably having a
nervous breakdown as we speak but you
know hey ho we're looking forward to
some food
but yeah I wouldn't wish it on anyone
welcome to All Hustle Road good to see
you guys um this is it
on the back of today's performance
one of you will be going through to the
final
first time in 10 years I've ever handed
my restaurant over to any chef this is
my baby three Mission Stars everything
I've ever worked for in 25 years is
inside this restaurant it's got to be
absolutely perfect
this is the climax
one of you is going through to the final
good luck off you go
the teams are working one of the most
well-equipped kitchens in Britain with
the finest ingredients money can buy
I challenge both chefs to create one
dish using the best quality English lamb
which I provided
it's incredibly flavoursome but a
challenging meat to cook perfectly
thank you Cynthia you can respond as
well please
four covers away table one four loin of
lamb
hello yes sir thank you oh my God come
on guys
fish tonight akhtar has raised the bar
yet again
he's serving a roast smoked loin of lamb
on cauliflower and potato with a
caramelized onion and saffron gravy
[Music]
it'll be ambitious with 44 ingredients
the most complicated dish currently on
my menu here has only 19.
akhtar has marinated the loina lamb
overnight in traditional Indian spices
smokes the meat with charcoal before
searing it then bakes it for six to
eight minutes
akhtar blanches the cauliflower and
potato base and Fries it with herbs and
spices
and then serves his dish with an onion
and saffron gravy
if akhtar doesn't blend the spices with
perfect Precision he'll ruin the entire
dish
to pull this off requires a level of
skill near genius
[Music]
come on
we've always said you know there's only
one place for us and that is winning it
uh we we didn't say you know we'll you
know we're happy hold this for me please
um be careful he's a ladel because
you're gonna burn my hands so the idea
behind the dish was what we've got
Rajasthani style marinades
um which is smoked with then cloves and
then we've got a mogul style gravy
that's they introduce the use of cashew
nuts and caramelized onion and that's
served with a uh potatoes and
cauliflower which is cooked in a North
Indian Punjabi Style with the fresh
fenugreek got a green saffron for the
potatoes no the saffron's actually in
the uh the the gravy and the gravy yeah
that's right the dish is a little bit
too complicated it's adventurous again I
just hope this time it doesn't come back
to bite them on the ass
laughs
very nice that looks lovely go please
let's go
[Music]
it's very spicy
it's spicy yeah
[Music]
it's tasty
I'm an actress cooking history
standard anyway so it's only if you
think that they're in just opportunity
to cook this wonderful
[Music]
in stark contrast to aktar's Dish
Ernesto has chosen to wear with just a
handful of flavors
[Music]
today if we win that should be something
incredible for my life it's a simple
dish lamb kebab with a potato salad and
mint chutney
Ernesto maronesi's Cube loin of lamb and
smoke paprika cumin coriander and garlic
and then he threads it onto fresh steaks
of Rosemary with red pepper and onion he
mixes purple and baby new potatoes with
a dressing of olive oil lemon juice and
creme fraiche and add sliced radishes
and herbs
the Chutney is a simple mix of Ginger
chili and mint
Ernesto griddles his Kebab until his
charred on the outside this is
definitely the first time a kebab has
been served at Royal Hospital Road it's
something I'd expect to see on the menu
at Santa Maria but today I'm looking for
a dish worthy of a three Michigan Star
Restaurant
okay talk me through the dish because it
sounds a bit Plain Jane doesn't it in
terms of boring yes Kebab but it's not
just an average Kebab it's a special
Kebab special garage with the Rosemary
stick something natural what does the
Rosemary do inside that land
Rosemary lamb is the best combination
favorite so you've got mint in the
marinade and rosemary running through
the lamb yes so you think the Simplicity
the Simplicity is the best point yeah
and the grill will be the over
complicated yes we need to find things
easy to make rice yes food boom play it
ready oh next table and I think that is
keep dancing you know today's about
raising the bar and taking a dish to a
different level to make it absolutely
exceptional has he got the aspirations
to go higher or is he going to just stay
in that mainstream Grill
[Music]
but it looks incredibly delicious simple
Jeff go please table five let's go thank
you well done now four more away
[Music]
strong on the Garlic's
if you ask a fuller player where he
would like to play they will say wemble
if you are someone too cool they would
say Gordon Ram's kitchen this is
Cathedral of cooking so I think they are
very nervous but I think they will do it
okay what you get from Santa Maria's
passion through and through there's no
there's no egos you know it's about them
as a team not about one individual and I
think more than anything this guy Cooks
from the heart Santa Maria has all
connected bonded and it shows and yet
these two here there's no teamwork
there's no no support there your donkey
I told you to put on fresh two on that
was overcooked
now you two okay we're fine Jeff we're
fine we're because it's not looking like
the most dynamic team together but we're
singing off the uh same here
generally it's like there couldn't be
any further apart that's how mistakes
come in
is that a bit hot for you Jeff to me is
that a bit hot for me I just tasted it I
thought it was delicious but you've got
this [__] thing that I've yeah I I
think you're quite a talented guy
unfortunately Cockiness rides over your
talent you just turned around and looked
at me and said is that a bit too hot for
you not in that way not us okay well why
am I supposed to take it you're not here
to blow smoke up my ass and secondly
more importantly I thought the dish was
delicious but before you ram it down my
throat it's just nice to back off a
little bit and show a little bit of
humility I just thought fine I'm allowed
to have I'm not stopping you from
allowing your thoughts but there's a
difference between thinking and ramming
down someone's Strokes I just thought
Jeff that you found it quite
uncomfortable what I was trying to say
at that point was not was it too hard it
will it will cut once the cream goes
into it oh yeah that again I want to
taste the base before you finished it so
I can see it through different stages
soon how clever it is to get from that
to the final dish
hustle
let the food do the talking pipe down a
little bit and put that big mouth big
boy attitude into your food that will
get you through the final how long for
the last two please
we're plating up now here okay great
well done good so service is over and
it's time to discover the truth of my
distinguished guests
in terms of the carriage today called
balasan how was that for you the iPhone
extraordinary dish it is produced and
The Taste and texture saffron sauce
beautifully blend super a bit well
presented well garnished and I loved it
I think I just done it it is in the
final footage
talking about the lamb kebab how was
that it was perfect particularly the
sauce yes in terms of the lamb kebab and
the lamb Curry which one do you prefer
the lamb kebab fascinating sir
I think this place
we happy with that very happy yeah yeah
good time was great food tasted great
what was more impressive than anything
is how the team Works Sean well done
thank you thank you
I am 100 happy in this great place this
amazing restaurant is is a dream I am
very very happy everything was amazing
very very good how was that for you
um
it wasn't um
I wouldn't say it was the best service
of my life we're happy the dish
um yes I was totally happy what's going
on the teamwork what happened there
Teamworks I mean the way we communicate
because obviously there was the issue of
the language barriers so and so forth so
it's it's quite simply just blunt
instructions can you follow this follow
that I want you to do so well I know
that Chef I know you've put so much into
this and you know throughout the whole
process you've been so supportive and
you know everything you've said I have
taken on board right well done
[Music]
some people may look at me and think I'm
cocky I'm arrogant I'm unapproachable I
mean chefs obviously got that impression
of me but
I'm not like that at all it's just
throughout the years we've always
we've always been knocked for our
approach by people within our industry
four you know pushing the barrier not
being
you know go with the flow of what's
available what's out there
and taking the easier approach and I
guess it's a
defense mechanism that we built up
I'm not here to offend anyone I didn't
want to offend a chef but this doesn't
mean a lot to me
the fact that I was able to cook at the
kitchen today
have my
my rest my menu item on on Chef's menu
card
another
that has overwhelmed me and you know I'm
not mad I'm not a very emotional person
but I just
it's been very tough for me today and I
didn't want it to end up this way
[Music]
only one Russian can go through to my
grand final and tonight who stays and
who goes is my decision
right now
I'm facing an impossible task honestly
who's got the edge
[Music]
thank you
I don't know right now
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to Royal Hospital Road
I'm about to choose one restaurant to go
through to the Grand Final of my
competition
will it be Santa Maria Del Sur
or lassan
in very different ways they are both
exceptional restaurants
before I make my choice I'm going to
taste the dishes cooked here tonight by
Ernesto and akhtar
right Santa Maria lamb kebab doesn't
sound the most glamorous but it looks
fantastic a nice potato salad purple
potatoes
and waxing new potatoes so with the mint
chutney
wow
the mint chocolate is made with rice
wine vinegar jalapeno pepper really nice
and vibrant and sort of wakes up that
lamb
I was a little bit worried when I first
saw the dish in terms of the Simplicity
Factor but
um
delicious in terms of taste lovely warm
potato salad stunning kebab and the most
amazing mint Chutney yeah brilliant that
was it close your eyes and wow this is
heaven absolutely delicious lesson
presentation quite fiddly yet you'd
expect that from
raktar
hmm
wow absolutely phenomenal anyone can
cook lamb like that but not anyone can
make a gravy as delicious as that you
taste it and it it blows your mind away
I mean it's just phenomenal I mean
absolutely delicious talented talented
cook without a Shadow of Doubt
unfortunately the biggest problem is
himself and I'm faced with a tough tough
choice lassan they they they hit the
heights but boy do they come down
crashing big time but the food up there
is extraordinary when it gets there
Santa Maria consistently good every day
haven't put a foot out of place yet this
is a very tough call
so it's the moment of truth
two outstanding restaurants but only one
can win a place in the Grand Final
okay
first of all to all of you yeah
seriously well done I really mean that
really well done absolutely phenomenal
okay
Santa Maria
I love the passion
absolutely love it and it's a breath of
fresh air to see not just the chefs but
the service at such an exciting level
Everything You Touch Is about passion
and it shows across the board those 20
main courses were phenomenal the mint
sauce was exceptional
the text of the Lamb yeah absolutely
delicious you weren't even working on
charcoal and you still managed
to put that flavor in it really well
done
weaknesses
got slightly nervous when I saw just
three things on the plane could you put
something else on there in terms of a
grilled vegetable or a a salad could you
push the boundary out even further I
gave you the perfect opportunity today
to really show off
I thought the dish was outstanding we
delivered
could you have done any more
who knows
the Sun
the first minute
I walked into that restaurant I was
excited and Blown Away by the level of
ambition you're pushing the boundaries
out like no other restaurants within
your category unique flavor I mean very
unique flavor and you don't really
expect to find that little bit of magic
there but it's like wow give me more of
that
lows when you get excited
about reaching the top it can't be done
individually
it has to be done with a team that's not
one in the kitchen one in the dining
room that is everybody
to take everybody to where you want to
go
now there's only one restaurant that's
going through to the final
[Music]
decision so far let me tell you that
and I really mean that
the restaurants let's go through to the
final
[Music]
foreign
now let the food do the talking okay
that dish was unique
really well done thank you okay
and I can't wait to see how you perform
in the final I want to disappointed you
and your team
yeah yeah sure well done really well
done congratulations and you come here
you ah well done absolutely brilliant
that was a difficult decision for me and
you are one talented Chef never forget
that it is a bit of a shock there is a
bit of a shock and then I'm Still Still
sinking in so on to the final and
and Beyond yeah
I'm just looking forward to getting back
in there celebrating with the team
both restaurants produce food worthy of
Royal hustle Road tonight I'm very proud
of them but ultimately I saw real
flashes of Genius in the dishes act are
created
Lassen has the potential to be one of
the Great Indian restaurants an actor
thorough deserves his place in the final
I bet everyone will tell you I've been
[Music]
quite horrible to be around
this means a hell of a lot
and
a dream come true doesn't sum up
what this means to me
in my second semi-final
three more restaurants three more
challenges
we'll compete against lassan in the
Grand Final
B absolutely perfect
one of you is going through the final